hey guys we're here with the official
firestorm character breakdown for
injustice to now this was taken directly
from a nether realm live stream so if
you see something weird remember that
it's a work in progress and don't forget
to Like and subscribe to keep up with
all of our injustice - coverage there's
some kind of catastrophic meltdown huh
there could be speed of kettles on
meltdown there's a transition I knew it
let's take a look at firestorm
well firestorm is a really really great
Zoning character a nuclear badass he is
a nuclear-powered badass ah two minds
are better than one so that makes him
good I um he has a really good set of
normal attacks and they don't have the
greatest range you're gonna kill the
budget let's just make it leagues you
see no I do that too sometimes there we
go they don't have the best range but
they do have overhead loads of them this
one envelope overhead this one ends in a
low he has a pretty long string here
they can used in combos so what would he
want you to put what's his game style
what's his game plan his game plan is to
keep you far away and develop his
character power which we'll get to in a
minute
okay so let's go over a special moves
one thing I'll note though for later
this is his best overhead attack which
splats them and doesn't it just does a
little ice chicken damage so it's just a
decent over net but we'll come back to
that later okay we remember that we're
gonna come back better you saw that yeah
remember you saw that so his main
fireball is very very fast it does a lot
of damage and it's a high the meter bird
watch is a mean that does a boatload of
damage and it's extremely fast yeah I
ridiculous
so once you've established your fire
balls you can use this multi track which
is really cool move that you have to
control whether close medium or far and
if it hits it stuns the opponent you
don't get a combo but it staggers them
and you can go right back to your
fireball game but if you meter Burton
you get a second mole trap
I'm not moving and now you get a combo
and look at those awesome yeah oh it
looks amaze let's let's play out yeah so
yeah that's great
plenty of time yes yeah you every day
you're there yeah and that's the idea
because he's meant to be played from a
distance so you can do it and you have
plenty of time to get in and do your
combo so this move is gonna check the
opponent who's trying to dash in who's
trying to just walk away they're gonna
have to go low to block that because
it's a full screen low attack and that
Able's him to go in so you're wondering
how do you get it how do you get it he
has this for pedo move where he actually
turns into nuclear fire and goes all the
way across the screen very quickly
nuclear fire that's your typical [ __ ]
yeah I know that yeah new killer 5 he
can also do this move in the air hmm so
this is a really really good move to
close the gap very quickly and if you
see somebody jumping yeah if the
opponent is trying to jump back to get
away it's a great move to beat that look
at that good stuff and it's a good move
to use in the air to even get behind
them
you can get away and then you're saying
well what if I have the live leaders
talk to them so hey Sarah dude wait is
that
is that just me hey what if I have to
like me and you want to sit on it right
I was tonight
you're afraid Superman does a lot of
damage right he sure does he gets him he
could lose light happy life right right
he has this energy shield which does
above he catches on fire and now he
takes reduce damage sure
so everything Superman does will do
significantly less damage you see that
super combo just bad I'm very surprised
you do that and then finally he has this
first which is a big burst attack which
it's a great wakeup attack it's a great
move to use at the end of your combos
and I'm just gonna sit here in June
thanks for shopping it also hits when
they're not jumping it does Peter Burton
one is actually a composter get a
battery and then go into your compost so
if you can do some real plants up with
all those tools you can a bit of penal
people can not us just throw my favorite
solo yeah it's great
so earlier I said he's really good to
keep you in and waiting for his
character power to build so it seems
like that's probably a good time to talk
about it should we or should we just
wait for may 16 know if I'm gonna get
hurt I'll be shoving a vote I vote for
now I say now Matt cool May 16 alright
so you'll notice there's three bars and
it's slowly building up the way it works
is it has three levels and we're waiting
for it to build up and it builds up
naturally over time he doesn't have to
do anything there's nothing you want to
do to start off is we can't his
character power is not filled at the
beginning of threat of the fight you
have to wait for it to fill up now when
it fills up you hit the character power
button and you'll get powered up this
makes all of his moves do more damage
and he heals you can actually see he's
getting he's healing as he bill
so that's level 1 level 2 level 2 does
the same thing but a little bit better
now he's healing for double his boobs
are doing even more damage and some of
those moves get different reactions now
if you can get all the way to level 3
which does take a while this is
something you're only going to be able
to do once or twice a match it's he
really gets powerful well let's see it
so he's getting more health back and
this changes a bunch of the reactions
for example this is now a combo start
all of his moves - significantly
boarding look at this fireball it
actually knocks down not just the
regular and look at that that's heavy
but that's a heavy push back right all
of us the heavy heavy push back
everything is just stay away this is
another one this normally it knocks you
down it's a low attack it's nice to mix
up with his overheads with this
character power line it actually becomes
a condom start right and just something
that I want to talk about I'm really
excited about the-- you saw Steve going
into the HD options you can now
specially set different character powers
to what you want them to be doing in
your practice so you try to keep
resetting to do things which i think is
a really cool quality of life
improvement oh it's you put in as a cat
one player it's it's a great blessing to
be able to have five scratches or this
is a firestorms a great example to where
you can start at level three so if you
want to practice your combos you don't
have to wait for it to recharge like you
have your latch so the idea of firestorm
your basic game plan will be when you
start off he has great distance moves
and up close he's okay but it's nothing
spectacular but if you can get this
level free if you can go the whole match
without needing it all of a sudden is up
close game becomes
twice as good as it was if he's a real
threat and the opponent is gonna have to
basically try to run away and let that
run out so he doesn't have blue fire he
has it for quite a while and he has it
for quite a while now the thing is maybe
you don't want to wait for level three
maybe you want to heal so maybe you're
about to lose the round it might be a
good idea to go to all the one or go to
level two get a little health pack do a
little bit more damage close on the
round but you got to consider you're
going to have a harder time getting
level three later in the game so there's
a lot of character power management here
when do you want to actually activate
you got to make choices right and when
you've built up a bar you can't hold on
to it it's not like scarecrow where you
have to use it so you could sit on level
three till you're comfortable in a good
position to use it right sure let's
understand this
[Music]
splice and Adams over here yeah so to me
I think ultimately firestorm is going to
appeal to very patient methodical
players that are going to be comfortable
keeping people away and waiting for
their opportunity but then the nice
thing is once he gets this going that's
when you can get really creative so the
creative players that like the rush down
dollop a little too so if you kind of
want to be patient patient patient and
then when it's your time absolutely go
in and go nuts he's definitely someone I
would say you think your play if you're
playing a grappler you're like Swamp
Thing like the good thing is if you get
in his way cups are fine right but like
you can do some serious stuff when
you're up close right against him so he
definitely has a very distinctive way
they'll play yeah all right so what do
we got that's special for him all right
I really like this color if they're
really cool and yeah all right so the
first character ability will show is
melting point whoa hey which is a very
quick freaking attack a lot of his
special moves are like full screen moves
or moves to get in so this one is
actually one you can use up close you
can it's a great combo ender it's a
great move to use just push them away if
you want to then use his full distance
moves
right because I mean for the most part
he does want to generally stay away
right until of course he gets his
character power up and then it's party
time yeah
it also looks absolutely awesome his
other one that we have here is atom bomb
which is a close medium and far bomb
that he places on the screen it will
then blow up and you can do it car you
can do it from close so something you
can put on the screen and the opponent
has to look for it and that again build
you time for your character power and it
can limit them dashing up like maybe you
think they're going to try to come in
because of this you can set it up and
they get pushed far away and if they
block it they get pushed far away and
again this is only a taste of some of
the movies will be guess so this is me a
great move for one of those methodical
careful players that likes to set traps
and keep them coming away and then this
one is the opposite this is for the
players that like to just go in you want
to just rush down you want to do big
flashy combos or maybe you like to do
both and you can equip both I got it on
the slowdown it's gonna go pretty
awesome
check what else you put together Steve I
think you did good work on the gear sets
the quality is weak I like this one very
futuristic like the blowing matrix yeah
I would say that most of things you wear
your futuristic thanks Tyler thanks for
the support I mean right spoon worried
yeah all right so I know what you're
thinking
mmm you've shown how great is ranges
what about what about Deadshot what
about dr. fate
what about character is that his own him
out what will he ever do well I do I
have a load up for you this is vaporized
we can actually leave the fight line he
can well out he can while out he's out
of here and you can hold this down and
you could be gone where did he go where
did he go I don't know
so say I'm like where does he go in
there we don't know we don't know he
actually leaves our reality and becomes
pure energy in his head cannon again no
that's for free oh cool cool and the
second one is one of my favorites it's
the air-ground spark where any point in
your jump you can some of this on the
ground it's a low attack and it locked
them down so this would be really great
against maybe Superman as this heats a
nap you jump up see it and it gets
launched up and then the meter burn is
even cooler double-hit does a big
shopping day chunk of damage and keeps
them up there and it keeps them up there
so when you combine this with this air
torpedo and it's pretty good jump
attacks you can control the air if you
have this equip
there it is there it is cool yeah oh I
think that's that is fire stores but I'm
sorry should we show the super one more
time I think we should Armenian solution
okay I'd like to do twice nice there we
go thank you Steve for that
what contribute another one on you this
is controller one all right guys it is
nap time for birthday shout out for
birthday shadows